over than that and across the sea such
an adventure I'm brush to see if young
man over traveling and conquer Bay
Canada you're so tall hi guys so we are
in our first hostel and it's cold hi
Niagara right hostelling international i
agree i think I ya know hi nog yeah
that's right we're lucky enough to get
sponsored accommodations and look we got
our own awesome room it's just for us
and a hostile and I dipped the devil on
the bottom obviously Laura's really away
ok let's go out and actually do things
they can I go explore set me up with
door
so outside the hostel that was staying
here they have some really cool
abandoned houses and some of you might
know that I have a thing for abandoned
houses so i'll show you the first one
it's really cool I wish we could get in
there but it just looks so well boarded
up how cool is that that would be so
good for our movie I love the colors of
it as well I'm showing them the haunted
houses this is the second one which
looks pretty awesome it's as high
voltage on it as well and it's quite
important so we just had some really
nice men come and tell us that this up
apparently was a police station not
prison but kind of close so yeah Carly
its like 100 years ago
now hey Laura who put the lights on the
thing my dad so many lights
hello so at the moment it feels like
it's raining but it's not just the falls
good morning so I woke up super early
this morning because I had a nightmare
about trying to save a child from a
murderous killer kidnap a guy and I had
no weapons or I had to get a weapon from
the kitchen but no matter how much I
fought him he would always get back up
and then I had to follow the cries of
the child to free them and save them
from the house that was bigger on the
inside like the TARDIS but not not as
fun so yeah anyway let's go get
breakfast and see what the day has in
store for us
so we're back in the car on the road
again this morning we met guy in the
kitchen he told us about this amazing
thing called nightmares at Niagara Falls
and it's basically where you walk around
and pitch black people scare you and
party lowes people chicken out and it's
absolutely terrifying and I was like
Laura we need to go and she was like oh
you go so we're going it's curry so good
veronese nightmares Fear Factory
following audio in all right we just
went through the nightmare the Niagara
Falls and it wasn't actually a scary I
think we did all right yeah I think it
was pretty cool I got trying to get some
audio so maybe that will work out but
Laura did get really scared and she hit
me in the face so no hope you can see
but my lip is actually leading more from
zoos we had this picture taking over and
it pretty much sums up a whole
experience
much may fall miss dropping we're
walking through the streets of Niagara
Falls when dinosaurs appeared all right
I just hopped over the fence and now
Laurie sorry Carl or a stuntman or you
can do this myself don't worry okay fine
so we had to jump over a fence we didn't
have to but we wanted to improve our
French to get the car and to never jump
a fence do never do never jump offense
when wearing tights is I have the most
ginormous ripping my tights right now
and it's so uncomfortable but we're
about to go down behind the falls and
under me
and how's that for storage
excited Laura
hi guys so our time in Niagara Falls is
over and we are journeying forth toward
Toronto never let you can see it there
tempest cool and loris so excited
how'd you do it bird knows Fred's been
jumping on the other bread and then jump
at down and then jumped on the part
again and gym mat down for ages as soon
as I put my camera out stops doing over
the plan and across the sea